tell us about this deal tell us the nuts
and bolts of this who wins who loses the
nuts of both of it is that Charter
finally got what they wanted which is
Time Warner Cable after you know Betty
Lou pointed out two years they did have
to pay up for it but I think they're
happy to pay up for the scale the Time
Warner Cable brings to the table so
certainly this makes them the second
largest cable company in the US and
probably the third largest video
provider right if you're if you assume
DirecTV and ATT clothes so what happens
to the other cable operators now is a
game on with consolidation I think
you're right I think it's it is game on
with consolidation I think you're still
early on in terms of consolidation in
the industry there are other companies I
privately-held Cox and Mediacom and
obviously cable vision with six here in
New York I think the market is wondering
what happens to the Dolan family and how
they think about cable there were rumors
that maybe they might be interested in
some order cable right certainly and I
think with all T's coming in a French
cable company coming in and becoming a
new buyer of cable assets in the US
industry that changes everything if I'm
a Time Warner shareholder today how do I
feel I think you weren't applied right
the stock is up is five six percent I
think initially people were assuming the
deal would come at come in at 180 so
certainly 195 is 10 percent higher than
what a lot of people were expecting okay
talk to me about John Malone you you see
him doing a lot of stuff in Europe 15
years ago he was more or less the person
people were talking to about cable in
this country and then 15 years later he
just doubled backs he wouldn't he would
not give up you said he wanted this deal
yes he's the he's the vision behind this
deal I mean he is the cable cowboy he
founded the US industry right the u.s.
cable industry so for him to make this
return is a big deal it is a huge deal
do you think that he's gonna have to
lend some money to this deal I think
this morning he did I think he paid a
pretty big paycheck to get Comcast I'm
sorry to get Charter and Time Warner
Cable together through Liberty broadband
and Liberty interact pay too much I
think it takes a very long term view and
I think it's rare that John Malone would
pay too much for anything
he's a cheapskate this this is one of
those things the the reason that the
other deal blew up with Comcast was
because their regulatory concerns should
that be taken for granted in this deal
as well I think you cannot take
regulation or regulatory approval for
granted anymore particularly because
broadband is just so important to the US
consumer sure this is a very different
deal I think there are there are no hard
caps in the US but certainly Comcast
Time Warner Cable that hit kind of 57
percent of broadband share this is
somewhat shy of 30 percent so a very
different deal so are they gonna have to
give up its chart or gonna have to give
up any assets then are we gonna see some
sales in order to make this deal happen
I think it would be surprising for
investors to see divestitures but we
don't know what kind of conditions there
could be on this on it on the regulatory
approval process what is this gonna mean
for consumers
you know consumers have a pretty
negative view on their cable company
this is this will be a positive for
consumers right because I think Charter
has done a really good job at turning
around the video business and providing
faster speeds to consumers I think
they'll do a similar playbook once they
get Time Warner Cable and primary cables
Ben there's so much of the focus has
been on operations these days what
speaking of operations I mean give me
the history of how Charter has been able
to integrate companies into its fold I
mean are we gonna see a pretty seamless
transition here or are there gonna be
some some hiccups I think outside of
regulation integration is always the
second biggest risk for these M&A deals
you know I would just highlight that
Charter bought Bresnan a few years ago
they they pretty much integrated that
asset within 12 months and were able to
get some pretty good synergies here and
over the last 12 to 14 months because of
Comcast's Charter has been very vocal
and working together with Time Warner
Cable and that management team to to tee
up great land communication which was
once part of the the proposed Comcast
Time Warner Cable deal we so we have a
little less than a minute left I just
wanted to ask you about Liberty's
involvement of this I think John Malone
has a very strategic vision for the
industry he also owns media assets I
would point out like Discovery stars
and Lionsgate now so certainly I mean
it's just interesting you know it's I
mean 12 months and we're back here again
with charter buying Time Warner Cable I
mean if you were a Time Warner Cable
shareholder you're happy today but you
kind of went through 12 months of you
know huge uncertainty and kind of you
know a little bit of stomachaches I
think right yeah you got a nice outfit
you got a knockout bid from charter this
morning good pay off